teen vogue is teaching young girls
uh how to perform witchcraft with
their bodily fluid i'm not this is not i
know it sounds like a joke like i'm
this is real the headline from teen
vogue this is a magazine aimed at
i guess 12 to 17 year old girls i think
is the target demo
headline menstrual blood magic three
spells for your period
how to make menstruation magical
always remember that magic is for
believers but this column can also
simply serve as a guide to getting in
touch with yourself
magically or not so it's not just purely
metaphorical here they're talking about
actual witchcraft rather than play into
this patriarchal shame
of the stigma of menstruation quote
witches and
other masters of magic believe
menstruation
is a gift from nature
and then it goes on and it's talking
about owning our power protecting
unwanted negativity
energetic fields healing chakras by
becoming one with our own body
they're actually serious about this
stuff
i think i know this is going to sound
radical to some people
on the right who are who are free speech
absolutists
i think this sort of thing ought to be
discouraged
i don't think our our founding fathers
would have considered this
you know uh instructing 13 year old
girls
in menstrual witchcraft i don't think
they would have considered that
the purpose of the first amendment uh i
think they probably would have
considered this obscene
prurient content i'm not sure
that this is exactly a blessing of
liberty please pardon
to the squishy conservatives who support
drag queen story hour too
we should discourage this kind of thing
a lot of people say that we need to
permit all kind literally all kinds of
speech and behavior or virtual
almost all kinds of speech and behavior
because otherwise
what's there are otherwise we're going
to end up with the salem witch trials
basically right we're going to these
women we're going to for things they've
said and done and we don't even know
we're going to
persecute them for that these are
literal witches
you know the the problem with the salem
witch trials
is uh presumably some of these women
were not witches you know
but what it what is in the argument like
well there's no such thing as witches
well i don't know these people seem to
think they're a lot they're witches
so i suppose a witch trial is
appropriate
[Music]
goodness gracious me i'm reminded always
when these sorts of crazy things come up
of uh i think my single favorite quote
in all of politics
churchill reagan lincoln pericles
all pale in comparison to one quote from
from pat robertson
in 92 i think it was and he said quote
the feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women
it is about a socialist anti-family
political movement
that encourages women to leave their
husbands kill their children
practice witchcraft destroy capitalism
and become lesbians
and so everyone laughs at this quote you
know
pat you crazy pat robertson what are you
oh my gosh here's the proof
this is like now whenever we read a
story about how the frickin frogs
actually are turning gay and we say oh
my gosh alex jones was right
well i read this teen vogue article and
i say oh my gosh pat robertson
we should have listened if only we had
listened
29 years ago perhaps we could have
avoided this
yo ring that bell like and subscribe
also though while i've got you while
i've got your attention
i know you're on youtube head on over to
apple podcasts
spotify google play wherever you listen
to your podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show we
want to avoid all sorts of shenanigans
that the big tech companies play
we want to make sure you are always
getting those updates
if you wouldn't mind leave a five star
review we sure do like that i very much
appreciate that we'll see you next time
[Music]
you